hello believe nation today I'm going to
talk about seven ways to develop an
unshakable belief in yourself
so self confidence and self-belief is
one of the biggest issues that I feel a
lot of entrepreneurs go through people
ask me all the time where do I get my
belief from how do I get more
self-confidence what do I need to do to
believe in myself more to push my
mission forward and so today I'm gonna
show you how I went from this guy I
think the very first step for any
entrepreneur who wants to get started is
to figure out what type of business that
they want to run and you always want to
build it around something you're really
passionate about - the guy I am today
now that video clip is only three years
old which is super surprising it's been
insane to see for myself how much I've
grown in my confidence in myself belief
in my ability to put out content and be
on camera in just a short amount of time
so I'm going to share with you seven of
the ways that I've done it that
hopefully you can model and apply in
your life in your business as well
so number one is find your one word the
self-awareness is super important
knowing what I stand for really helped
me defend the positions that I had in my
life when people were doubting me
knowing that I st. for believe and
knowing how that breaks down into
passion self confidence and conviction
and knowing really deeply have an
understand of myself when you truly know
yourself you have a lot more confidence
it's easier to say no to people it's
easy to dismiss other people's opinions
of you because you have your own opinion
of yourself where if you don't know what
you stand for if you don't really know
who you are you don't have that
self-awareness then anytime somebody
says something about you you take it in
and say maybe I'm like that oh maybe I'm
not good enough maybe their opinions are
right where I couldn't care less you
don't like the Blue Jays you don't like
what I'm wearing you don't like my
message I feel like you know you might
be wrong but it's not gonna impact my
self-worth it's not gonna impact my
confidence and belief in myself and so
understanding at the core Who I am
having a self-awareness know why one
word is is massively important and had a
big change on my life
number two is practice you know it's
hard to have a lot of belief in yourself
to do something when you haven't
practiced it when it's your first time
stepping out on the field you're
probably gonna be nervous you're going
probably gonna feel like I might make
some mistakes right your first time get
in front of the camera you're probably
gonna be super nervous and it's not
gonna go well and that's okay but the
more you practice and practice and
practice and practice then the more you
know that you can do it the more swings
that you take the more you know that
when you stand up to the plate you'll be
able to to do it you know for me and my
channel I've done almost 4,000 videos
that we haven't crossed 4,000 yet most
of them are public that's a lot of
practice the reason why I can grow
faster than other people is because I'm
just doing my work you can do it too
it's not that I'm that special you could
do the exact same thing in your business
whatever you feel like you're not
confident in if it's public speaking if
it's networking if it's talking to
people if it's sales if it's writing
copy if it's creating product one
understand do you want to get better at
that you know like I have no interest in
getting better at networking I don't
really care it doesn't drive business
for me I'm not particularly eager at
learning that new skill I'd rather focus
on other things but to for this helping
you want to get better at then just
practice commit to practicing more like
increase your output be prolific be
prolific whatever it is that you want to
go out and make whatever you want to be
the world's best at you need to practice
and be prolific once a week is not
enough you got to do it every day right
be prolific triple the amount of content
10x the amount of content 10x the amount
of practice that you're putting out
there whether it gets released or not
whether you're just practicing piano on
your own or practicing your sales
picture practicing your presentations or
tinkering away the next perfect coffee
cup whatever it is 10x the amount of
practice you're getting and then you'll
know when you actually get up and do it
you have the confidence because you've
done it so so so so many times before
number three is know your intentions one
of the things that I used to doubt
myself on a lot was challenging and
pushing people one of the things that
bothers me so much is somebody living
below their potential where I see
somebody with these limiting belief sins
excuses for why not doing better and I
see them playing up here like you could
do so much better you could be you can
have such a bigger impact and where
you're at right now and you're playing
small and I used to accept their reasons
that face value I used to accept that
you know they just don't they don't
agree with me and I'm not gonna convince
them and it's not worth the effort to
try and I don't want to offend them I
don't want to push them away I don't
want them to think less of me I don't
want my word to come off the wrong way
and for anybody who's been in my
mastermind group I had this mastermind
group that I've run for 10 plus years I
think in Toronto they've seen there the
shift in me on how much more passionate
I'll be and how much more aggressive
I'll be at pushing them past and getting
them to be where they could go and not
accepting their BS answers anymore for
everybody we all have BS answers and
what helps me is knowing that the intent
is positive I go in thinking I want this
person to get better it's gonna be
uncomfortable I'm gonna have to push and
poke at parts that they don't want to be
pushed and poked at and in case some
cases people that I don't really have
much of a personal connection with this
might be the first time I have a
conversation with them I don't want to
tolerate BS in my life I don't want to
tolerate being around anybody who's
living below what they could be doing
that untapped potential and so all I
gained more confidence being able to do
it because I know that my intention is
positive and has never actually come out
to bite me in the moment maybe in the
moment a lot of people would get
defensive it's supernatural
a lot of people will will fight back and
defend their you know erroneous
positions but then they always come back
booth is the next day or a week later
and after they think about it and cool
down they realize that they had been
living small and so the confidence to do
that came from knowing that my
intentions were positive I'm not pushing
you from me I'm pushing you for you
because I want you to be here because
you can't be here what are you doing
over here when you could be way up here
come on let's go let's do this thing
right it's always for them and so having
that
you know my back pocket knowing the
intention really helps me do the
uncomfortable things I need to get done
and again back to the other point with
practice the more I do it the better I'm
getting at it the faster I get to that
uncomfortable position and the faster
we'll continue to get and the better
we'll continue to get as I continue to
apply it
number four is visualize one of the
things that I found really helpful when
I'm about to go do something
uncomfortable whether it's you know
speak on stage do a big interview was to
get on camera have an uncomfortable
conversation with somebody in my life or
colleague or entrepreneur I would just
try to visualize it I try to roleplay I
try to walk through it
I don't roleplay with somebody here I
know that's really helpful for other
people for me I just try to imagine what
I'm gonna say how is it gonna go what is
it gonna look like what am i doing
whatever my hands moving how am i
walking am i sitting down how do I open
up the conversation it never goes
exactly like I visualize but just like
practice helps you get better and gain
more confidence when I visualize it it's
like I'm practicing in my head like I'm
tricking my mind that I've done this
already a hundred times I practice this
conversation a hundred times even though
it might be the first time I'm having
this conversation my head thinks it's
the hundredth time and so because I've
gone through it so many times I'm ready
to go and it had more confidence so that
visualizing that uncomfortable thing or
that thing that you don't believe in yet
or you have that self-doubt just
visualize doing it over and over and
over again and how are you gonna look
and how you're gonna act and what you're
gonna say I find really helpful and
helping me get that self belief
number five is get uncomfortable it's
good to get into the habit of forcing
yourself to be uncomfortable you know
your ability to do great things will
greatly depend on your ability to push
yourself past your zone of comfort and
so if there's something that you know
you need to do something that like to
get to that next level you have to go
through this then just practice getting
there as an example on my youtube
channel since we're making this video
here I used to need to have everything
scripted everything was scripted you go
way back to the earliest videos on my
channel
everything was scripted 100% I didn't
have any unique words that I injected
while I spoke it was always tacking it
out and then saying what I typed and
trying to memorize it and you can see me
a lot of times like looking up to the
left or stuttering I felt like if I
didn't see the exact words right then
then it's a fail video and I couldn't
improvise and I couldn't do it on the
spot and then I realized you know that's
not it's not the best way to do it
because when I go do an interview on TV
when I go do speeches and I get
questions asked to me I'm not gonna have
the questions in advance a lot of times
I'm not gonna know what they're gonna
ask me I can't prepare for it I
recognized that I needed to work on my
ability to be more spontaneous and so I
forced myself to do it in a low-risk way
with repetition which was making these
videos the interesting videos and some
of the ask Evan videos that I did way
back I might have a general thought but
I don't script anything else and I
purposely for the in spresso as an
example I don't look at the video
beforehand what happens Ivan who's on my
team will do the research he'll find the
video clip I will go to the studio or in
this case here and I'll just watch the
video and then stalk into the camera
like I'll spend a minute just thinking
about it and you just go and talk where
before I would have wanted to look at it
a week before thought about all the
options script everything out and now I
feel like it's much better and I'm
forcing myself to get better at it
whenever I do live interviews with
people they say hey okay we can send you
the list of questions and here's what
we're gonna talk about don't send me the
questions I have no interest in looking
at your question I want it all to be
live and spontaneous and I'm building
the muscle and I'm getting better at it
and so now I'm much more comfortable
doing any situation because I've done
I've gone through it before and I've
forced myself to be uncomfortable
getting uncomfortable just for the sake
of being uncomfortable
maybe some merit and value to that but
especially if you know that you have to
overcome this limiting belief or this
this negative mindset or this fear then
start doing it because as you do more
uncomfortable things your sphere of what
is comfortable to you gross and when
you're inside your comfort zone you have
unshakable confidence and belief so if
your comfort zone is this small then
you're always gonna be you're always
gonna have no confidence because the
only book fits into that little tiny
thing then you're confident you can do
it where if you build and grow that zone
of where you are confident then there's
a lot more things that you will have
unshakeable confidence in number six is
follow your habits and routines I find
that when you are doing something that
is unfamiliar what helps give me
confidence is finding a way to do what
is familiar do what is familiar in the
unfamiliar so what does that mean when I
go and do a presentation as an example I
have a series of things that I do all
the time so while that presentation may
be the first time I'm doing that
presentation it may be the the first
time I'm seeing that audience it may be
the first time in that city or that
country first time on that stage all
little lots of firsts I will practice my
speech beforehand and pace you know I'll
walk around my hotel room and pace and
practice I'll listen to music just
before going on stage right I'll listen
to music put some songs on that I you
know REM remember recognize peel me up
I'll usually I'll have a Starbucks I'll
have a Frappuccino you know whatever
city almost in the world is a Starbucks
I'll have a Frappuccino I might bring
that on stage with me I might finish it
beforehand but doing these things that
are familiar helps me in a situation
that I'm unfamiliar with it's kind of
like a childhood bedtime story you read
kids a bedtime story and then they go to
sleep that's their routine right they
expect that they're gonna fall asleep
during or after that bedtime story so
they brush your teeth they have a bath
and then they go have that bedtime story
and they fall asleep it's the same thing
for me I do these things I listen to
music I pace I have my Starbucks I
expect to then go off and do a amazing
presentation
and so those habits really helped me and
so finding those habits for yourself
could be super important tied in to this
I would also say the environment is
important habits and environment too
combined I think one of the biggest
thing that's changed about me person in
the past three years comparing that old
clip to where I am now is I've just
surrounded myself with so many
successful people through the videos
through the research before anything's
videos go up
I approve them I look at them and so
when we're doing the top 10 or believe
life or interests or any of these series
I'm feeding my brain with all of these
success people the best parts of what
they've ever said I'm constantly feeding
that into myself they haven't changed my
value system I still I still you know
believe and believe I'm still that same
person at the core but they've given me
more confidence they've given me more
boldness they've given me more audacity
they've allowed me to stretch beyond the
people that are in my immediate circle
to say great you guys think I'm doing an
amazing job
I'm nothing I want to go out and to have
this kind of impact that's what I want
to go and do as I have increased my
intake of that gold as we move from one
top 10 a week the two top tens a week
the five top tens a week to introduce in
the end stress a series to introduce in
a mentor me series the amount of content
that I've consumed has increased and
proportionately my audacity and
confidence and success has increased and
it's probably one of the biggest changes
that I've made over the past three years
of my life and just increasing the
exposure to greatness and the more you
expose yourself to great things great
people great ideas the more some of it
has to seep into you and it feels you
with more self-confidence in belief
and number seven for me is recognizing
your limiting personal beliefs this is
one of the hardest things for anybody to
do I think because we we tell ourselves
a story why we can't be successful and
admitting the truth is too painful and
for me because I had an insane desire to
please people I think more was I didn't
want to let people down I don't like
what letting people down and so I'm
always careful what I what I commit to I
don't commit to something that I don't
follow through on I'm always early for
meetings I'm always early for connecting
with people I'm always you know earlier
on time I don't like letting people down
which is a great thing to have but the
flip side is you don't commit to people
you don't commit to projects that could
be really good for you that could help
you grow because you are afraid of
letting somebody down and so you don't
do the thing that you should do for me a
lot of it was meeting with people
meeting with entrepreneurs going and do
presentations I would secretly hope that
they would cancel on me because I felt
like maybe I'm not gonna add value here
you know I don't want to let them down
so three days before an event or the day
of a meeting I would secretly open my
email and hope that there would be a
cancellation notice I got okay I don't
have to go do that and it was a limiting
belief for me and once I recognized it
they know was able to attack it then I
was able to you know the trick to
overcoming these negative limiting
beliefs is one after the fact
understanding that I did it again I did
it again ah why did I do it again you're
so frustrated that you did it again that
you're playing small again that you said
no again when you really wanted to say
yes right you did it again you did it
again didn't just the awareness that's
more than half the battle because most
of the things that are holding you back
you're limiting self belief you don't
even know it's not even on your radar
you just do them so subconsciously
then you have zero awareness around them
and that is gonna forever hold you back
so just having that kind of awareness
after the fact is super important the
more you pick it up the more you keep
track of it the closer you will get to
the point of it happening to the point
where I am opening my email and secretly
hoping that that person is gonna cancel
and catching it right then and there it
doesn't happen right away but with time
right then and there and then having the
courage
take the action that you're supposed to
take that is best for you instead of
cowering down instead of doing what you
always do
instead of saying no and backing down
and saying no it's okay you know instead
of being that the lowest form version of
yourself instead of putting yourself
into this tiny box and mean this little
tiny person where you could be a lion
having the courage to go for it and the
more you pick it up the more frustrating
is gonna be to the point where you just
have to say yes and do it and again
every major breakthrough I've had in my
life and my business has come from me
crushing one of these limiting personal
beliefs so this videos a little longer
than I expected it to be but hopefully
is super valuable for you guys those are
my thoughts on the seven ways to develop
an unshakable belief in yourself I'm
curious to know what did you guys think
of the video did you like it do you
resonate with something what was the
most important thing that I said that
touched you leave it in the comments
below I want to join in the discussion
also did I miss it eight nine ten is
there something that you want to add to
this list to round it off leave it down
below super curious to see what you have
to say and finally I want to give a
shout out to Justin from sixty five
drums comm Justin thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book really
means a lot to me thank you guys so much
for watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon